faire des ravages le vih doit entrer
dans les cellules immunitaires
il emprunte une sorte de porte surface
des cellules
certaines personnes laissent avec une
mutation génétique qui rend la porte
défectueuse
le virus ne peut pas entrer donc c'est
un extrait d'un reportage que vous
pourrez voir ce soir à l'émission
découverte sur les ondes ici télé à 18
heures donc c'est la journée mondiale du
sida selon le plus récent rapport de
l'onu sida environ 38 millions de
personnes vivaient avec le vih sur la
canette en 2018 et 770 milles sont
mortes d'une maladie liée au vih
cependant cette même année par ailleurs
montréal lance aujourd'hui une campagne
de sensibilisation 2 dont le slogan est
le plus dangereux avec le vih ce sont
les préjugés donc la ville veut
s'attaquer aux peurs et aux jugements
envers les personnes vivant avec le vih
alors pour en parler je reçois la
docteure sera minime mercure et les
responsable médical du service it et ss
et réduction des méfaits la direction
régionale de santé publique de montréal
bonjour docteur mercure bonjour donc en
2019 bientôt 2020 les préjugés sont
toujours aussi tenace envers les
personnes qui ont le vih ou est
séropositive malheureusement
malheureusement c'est ce qu'on voit dans
les études quand même si ce que nous
disent aussi les gens sur le terrain les
organismes communautaires les personnes
20 que le vih que en ce moment le pire
pour eux le plus dangereux c'est encore
les préjugés dont sont victimes donc ce
qui nous est si les traitements
fonctionnent bien on a moins d'effets
secondaires
on arrive à avoir une charge virale
indétectable
c'est ce qui arrive dans le fond quand
quelqu'un a le vih on va lui proposer un
traitement assez rapidement maintenant
avec les nouveaux traitements qui ont
beaucoup beaucoup avancé les personnes
vont obtenir une charge virale et des
cas ce qui fait en sorte qu'ils vont
avoir un bon état de santé
une espérance de
une qualité de vie qui est similaire à
celle de quelqu'un qui ne vivrait pas
avec le vih et en plus l'autre bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'avec une charge virale
indétectable donc un traitement efficace
le plus de transmission sexuelle du
virus donc pas de géant qui est énorme
alors c'est comme si la science avance
beaucoup en matière de vih mais les
préjugés pas assez pas aussi vite que ce
qu'on voudrait pcc comme la grosse
barrière en ce moment c'est ce que les
gens nous l'expliqué on ne meurt plus du
synode du sida en 2009 à moins de ne pas
suivre ses traitements j'imagine
et c'est à dire que dans des pays riches
comme le nôtre effectivement ne tous les
moyens pour ne pas mourir encore des
personnes qui sont diagnostiqués
tardivement à montréal a un style qui
serait le sud on les met sous traitement
et ils reprennent une qualité de vie et
un système immunitaire normal qui leur
permet de combattre les infections donc
dans les systèmes comme les nôtres
effectivement on a très très peu
sauf pour des personnes qui n'auraient
pas eu leur diagnostic donkey ce qui
serait pas aller se faire dépister avoir
avoir un test mais pour pouvoir
bénéficier de ce traitement avec son
très très efficace mais oui donc vous
parler de dépistage tardif parce que ça
peut avoir un lien avec justement les
préjugés qu'on peut avoir tout à fait
des ces personnes là donc on préfère ne
pas savoir quelques euros que
d'affronter les préjugés c'est le cas au
8 août a fait ça les gens nous disent
que les études ou si nous nous démontre
le fait que cette défection l'eau sont
encore très stigmatise ces conditions
leur fassent l'objet de préjugés
les gens préfèrent ne pas savoir ça les
coupes des services alors qu'on sait
maintenant que c'est la pierre angulaire
la partir du moment où en un diagnostic
on entre dans une prise en charge très
adéquat qui fait en sorte que les gens
vont être ensemble et vont pour vivre
une vie en fait tout à fait normal si ce
n'est des préjugés de c'est sûr que ça
vient avec des médicaments à prendre sa
vie avec des rendez vous médicaux avec
toute une prise en charge qui peut être
relativement lourde pour les personnes
mais quand tout ça est en place
quels thèmes vie équivalent et comment
expliquez vous le fait justement qui a
tous ces préjugés semble-t-il que ces
personnes là on sont moins bien traitées
souvent chez les dentistes ont encore
des craintes des sondages qui démontrent
quasiment le camp la population d'y
avoir peur de pouvoir contracter le
virus justement dans un salon de
coiffure ou alors ça tient à quoi c'est
un manque d'information où il ya un peu
des deux il ya des parts qui sont
irrationnels ont souvent la cause des
préjugés c'est ça il ya aussi toute
cette question là d'un manque de
compréhension de la transmission du vih
2 qu'est ce que c'est que cette que
cette infection le psy ce qu'on veut
faire avec avec la campagne qu'on lance
effectivement aujourd'hui c'est
d'informer les gens on sait que dans les
communautés les gens se sont beaucoup et
fort mais c'est quand on fait des
sondages auprès du grand public on voit
sur les gens savent pas que le
traitement est efficace
les gens ne savent pas qu'il ya des
traitements pour prévenir le vih non
plus quand on fait ces mêmes sondages le
auprès par exemple des communautés lgbt
un pourcentage beaucoup plus grand de
personnes sont au courant des avancées
de nos lectrices plus et ça donc les
communautés ont fait le bout de chemin
ce sont informés grâce entre autres aux
organismes communautaires qui ont
beaucoup beaucoup travaillé pour la
sensibilisation auprès des communautés
maintenant ce qu'on a besoin c'est de
parler au grand public pour qui ce fait
d'avoir peur des personnes vivant avec
le vih c'est ce qu'on essaie de faire
avec
avec cette campagne là qui vont rouler
dans le métro qui va être relayée sur
les médias sociaux qui vont également à
être en affichage sur les bornes
numériques dans la ville marie l'on veut
vraiment aller vers le grand public pour
que eux aussi s'informer connaissent la
réalité du vih en 2010 et la réalité du
vih ne touche pas que les clientèles
dont on parlait beaucoup évidemment
depuis les années 80 ça peut tout le
monde les migrants c'est des migrants
arrivent peut-être porteurs du virus et
puis 10e tabou d'en parler et la
population générale où ces personnes est
à l'abri personne n'est à l'abri tout le
monde effectivement peut vivre avec le
vih tout le monde les personnes qui est
immunisé contre le vih
naturellement effectivement qu'il ya des
communautés qui sont davantage touchées
que d'autres
donc les nouveaux diagnostics à montréal
par exemple c'est plus de la moitié qui
vont se retrouver chez les hommes qui
ont des relations sexuelles avec des
hommes
et encore effectivement comme vous le
mentionnez de nombreux diagnostics sont
chez des personnes qui arrivent de pays
où le vih est endémique encore de
nombreux diagnostics chez les personnes
qui utilisent des drogues par injection
mais il ya également des personnes de la
population générale effective
qui vivent avec le vih et quel est votre
objectif premier de cette campagne
qu'est-ce qui vous rendrait heureuse
comme et c'est justement ce que
j'aimerais beaucoup c'est que nos
prochains sondages montrent que les gens
n'ont plus peur des personnes 20 que le
vih est que les patients qui viennent
nous voir les personnes avec qui on
travaille de travail j'ai vu une
différence
maintenant les gens ne me regarde plus
comme si j'étais un pestiféré
comme si j'étais contagieux donc ça
serait pour nous le plus grand miroir il
doit aussi on sait que si on arrive à
faire ça à diminuer la stigmatisation
les gens vont se faire dépister que les
gens vont pour être traitée puis on va
arriver à éliminer le vih à montréal je
remercie beaucoup docteur mercure
d'avoir été avec lyon c'est à peu près
le très prisé au revoir